المضي قدمًا في فمك
منذ المرة الأولى التي أُعلن
فيها للجمهور أننا نزرع هذه ،
فهناك آلاف مقاطع
الفيديو على YouTube لأشخاص يأكلون Carolina Reapers في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، لكني استمتعت
بمعظمهم على الرغم من أنه يمكن  كن
مزعجًا ، ليس أمرًا خطيرًا أن
تأكل الفلفل الحار للغاية ، إنه تفاعل كيميائي
يدركه عقلك على أنه حرارة ،
لذا ستتوقف عن فعل ذلك
[موسيقى]
أنا أدخن في الكاري ، لقد
صنعت كارولينا ريبر لقد قمت بتربية
الفلفل في كلية مينه للتو  كنت
مهتمًا حقًا بالحصول على فلفل أكثر سخونة وسخونة
بمجرد أن جربتها ،
منحني Guiness الرقم القياسي العالمي
لأشهر أنواع الفلفل في نوفمبر 2013
لتربية هذه الأشياء ، لقد عبرت
فلفل شبح مع هابانيرو وما ظهر
هو هذا الفلفل الشرير الذي كان لديه
الثآليل على جميع البثور التي يطلقون عليها
، وفي المرة الأولى التي تذوقتها فيها
أصابتني ركبتي ، أجرينا
اختبارًا للفلفل بانتظام في
جامعة وينثروب بواسطة د.  كالاواي في
معمل الكيمياء يتم قياس جميع أنواع الفلفل
بواسطة وحدات Scoville الحرارية التي تخبرك
بمدى سخونة الفلفل.
وهي نقطة خمسة وستة وتسعة ملايين
وحدة حرارية من سكوفيل ، وهو الشيء الأكثر سخونة
في العالم عندما تأكل كارولينا
ريبر ، فإن الإحساس الأول الذي تحصل عليه يكون
حلوًا ، ثم فجأة تبدأ الحرارة
في الانطلاق ، مثل الاحتراق
بالحرق ، ثم تبدأ الأشياء الفسيولوجية في
عينيك  سوف يصابون بالدم
سيبدأون في التمزق والماء
والجلد يتدفق ، تبدأ في التنفس بقوة ،
لكن عملية التمثيل الغذائي لديك تبدأ في رفع
بعض الناس يقولون إن الأمر يشبه تناول
الحمم البركانية المنصهرة ، سيقول الآخرون إنها مثل
لعق الشمس بالنسبة لي إنه مثل تناول
فحم حجري وبغض النظر  ما
تفعله لا يمكنك التخلص منه
من مؤخرة فمك ، أعني أنه من
الجنون الكثير مما أفعله هو
تجارب إبداعية  ستبحث عن سمات في
فلفل واحد وستبحث عن سمات في فلفل
آخر وتحاول الجمع بينها
والاحتفاظ بهاتين السمتين ، هناك
مربيون آخرون يحاولون تحطيم رقمنا
القياسي ولكننا كنا نحتفظ
بالفلفل في جيبنا الخلفي.  التي هي
ضعف أو أكثر من كارولينا
ريبر التي يمكننا تقديمها إلى موسوعة جينيس
في أي وقت ، لقد تغير تصوري لماهية
حدود مدى سخونة
الفلفل مع
تقدم العلم على مر
السنين ، فقط أخبرني شيئًا ما يمكن
لن أنتهي ، سأجد طريقة للقيام بذلك
[موسيقى]